ces images datent de 1993
nous sommes en colombie dans une mine de
charbon artisanale entre les coups de
pioche de petites voix sortent des
entrailles de la terre des voix
d'enfants
[Applaudissements]
il y a dix sept ans nous avions réalisé
un reportage sur les enfants taupes de
colombie ces gamins qui travaillait
comme des forçats au fond des mines de
charbon nous y sommes retournés pour
savoir ce que ses enfants étaient
devenus
en 2010 le coeur de lamine ba toujours à
200 mètres sous terre
le rythme est toujours mécanique le son
métallique
le premier petit mineur que nous avons
retrouvés c'est luis oscar leonardo
rincon il avait 12 ans sur ces images
aujourd'hui dans un air vicié aussi
brûlants que son corps à 32 ans il avait
toujours son filon de charbon palabre
est ce que montrent les tic
la galerie peut s'écrouler à tout moment
tel est le destin d'oscar mineurs
colombiens
nous avons retrouvé oscars mais
également trois autres enfants taupes de
l'époque
son frère aîné herman lui a réussi à
quitter la mine un nouveau travail
il brasse aujourd'hui des caisses de
fruits en espagne
nous avions aussi filmé jairo il est
aujourd'hui militaire enfin nous avons
retrouvé son cousin riders
il répète tous les jours les mêmes
gestes sans autre avenir
[Musique]
la loi colombienne interdit le travail
infantile
ce nouveau reportage est l'occasion de
vérifier si des enfants
extrait toujours du charbon par 200
mètres de fond
il
[Musique]
dans la région du bo yaka au centre de
la colombie
de nombreux petits villages vivent du
charbon taupe haga et son église ont vu
naître oscar et sa petite famille
[Musique]
première source de chaleur et de revenus
le charbon brûle aussi les coeurs et
décimé famille la mine a pris un premier
mari oscar a perdu un fils de 2 ans
faute d'argent pour le soigner
[Musique]
winona le voeu le plus cher d'oscar que
c'est regard innocent ne connaissent
jamais la mine si ce n'est en images
pour le devoir de mémoire nous montrons
la famille le reportage que nous avions
réalisé voilà 17 ans c'est la première
fois qu'ils le voient
[Musique]
mais tout est en position se sont ils si
je pars amis vérifiables et l'autre vert
des médecins pour laurie mais cette
terre comme commente aline côté comme la
birmanie s'est rappelé m ottawa le monde
et non nos pères l'état règne au club
amigo mls et qu'on ne vienne pas au
pénal interdit mononoké madrid au camp
nou pour soulager en biens baissent de
leur connaît
selon papa chéri mais un
ap
[Musique]
ato paga l'extraction du charbon et
religion le travail de ces hommes est
respectée honoré jusque sur les murs des
maisons du village fresque réaliste
figées dans le temps l'intérieur des
maisons au confort précaire rappel cette
fatalité 17 ans ont passé et les petits
garçons de l'époque ont grandi rider
cassagne et d'assez marié et lui aussi
est devenu chef de famille mais avant ça
comme les copains il pioche et à 200
mètres sous terre
il a grandi mais aujourd'hui encore il
nourrit les siens grâce au charbon qu'il
extrait
[Musique]
nos collègues latéral qui n'inscrit la
petite aura gimena un mois et dix jours
vient de rejoindre sa grande soeur lina
mariana deux ans les deux jours de week
end se termine instants privilégiés avec
ses proches avant de retourner au
charbon option finance
[Musique]
l'asie
mais n'a pas ce sera bientôt respirer
quand le toit monde
[Musique]
perdu dans les montagnes du bouyaka à
six heures de route de chez riders se
trouvent les mines de san mateo où il
travaille
les mineurs sont payés à la journée et
au rendement ici jamais de vacances pas
de revenus fixes
ils gagnent entre 10 et 12 euros par
jour soit moins d'un euro de l'heure en
plus depuis quelques semaines ryder et
ses compagnons de labeur descente pour
pas grand chose
l'exploitation de la mine est à l'arrêt
à cause d'un accident lié au gaz un coup
de pioche à enflammer une poche de
méthane de treize compagnies
voilà
jean en face il ya maintenant la roja et
ya même des gays
saluons quand elle aborde là au cabinet
sacré 13 compagnies musicales strauss
kahn de péronnas
c'est le modèle que celle les rangers 4
étoiles et haletant
damon a attristé à villeréal et les
propos de la famille
vous notez qu'elle est à la rigueur
[Musique]
wen
capitale dacca
on
à cliquer
acquise et qu'on ne me restait hier
en 2009 en colombie ce genre d'accident
a causé la mort de 961 minutes
nous voulons
oh
[Applaudissements]
ils ont investi
présents
les uns veulent encore
le colloque est
boukari
c'est avant
le country été conquis
il faudra deux heures pour poser ce seul
était vital
entre son enfance est aujourd'hui rider
n'a pas vu grand-chose évolué
seule nouveauté un vieux moteur bricoler
pour remonter le bayonnais
des investissements ont été effectués
pour améliorer la productivité mais sans
jamais chercher à soulager les ouvriers
tout le reste des tâches se fait encore
à la force des bras
en fait c'est toujours un peu la
conquête de l'ouest
et
corinne cantona mi temps 10
l'inspiration
[Musique]
17 ans en arrière devant nos caméras
rider témoignait déjà ouvertement de ces
conditions de travail indignes tous les
jours lorsque je descends fond je risque
ma vie et j'ai peur j'en connais
beaucoup qui sont restés c'est très
dangereux ici les mines ne sont pas
entretenus ni étayé il n'y a aucune
sécurité et ça vous tombe sur la tête
comme un rien
[Musique]
gevo ma vie c'est ma vie
- d telle la prolétaire je suis veuve et
sans revenus c'est pour cela que mon
fils est obligé de m'aider en allant à
la mine moins trois heures par jour à
l'exception du dimanche son rôle à lui
c'est de décharger le charbon mais il ne
descend pas au fond ah bon tu va sauter
aussi vous voyez je ne sais même pas ce
qu'ils leur font faire là bas c'est vrai
c'est dangereux il peut y avoir du gaz
dans la mine
c'est pourquoi je préfère qu'il n'ya que
cette année et l'an prochain je renvoie
bogota faire un travail plus sûr
c'est aussi mieux pour les études dix
sept ans plus tard les regrets ont
remplacé les projets
certaines nations
il
c'est m
même moment sa une
économiquement il ya donc à tenir
tant cs mais on a mal à la corrida thé
noir
dès lors moins
en 1993 certains enfants tôt vous
descendez même avec leur mère souvent
abandonnés par leur mari elles n'avaient
pas d'autre choix que d'aller à la mine
elle aussi pour quelques pesos gagner au
prix d'efforts inhumain la mine
ce n'est pas un endroit pour une femme
comme moi je gagne moins qu'un homme
parce que je produis peut évidemment
j'arrive à peine à 15 francs par jour
oui ce qu'on vit ici c'est de l'esclave
[Musique]
lors du premier tournage
un des enfants avaient pris notre caméra
à témoins jairo castaneda
[Musique]
c'est le seul qui à l'adolescence a pu
quitter la mine aujourd'hui nous l'avons
retrouvée il est devenu militaire ils ne
risquent plus sa vie sous terre mais
dans la jungle
à l'autre bout du pays cela fait six
mois que jairo n'est pas rentré chez lui
contre l'ogcn emportant donne patricio
62 ans était lui aussi mineur
le voici il y a dix sept ans il a passé
toute sa vie dans le charbon qui
aujourd'hui consume ses poumons à petit
feu
ironiquement cette empreinte trattoria
nos aînés et pour notre espace d'ananas
faisait planter maintenant comme
nationale
si jean-noël resta aux dépens de serena
mène et akamai à nassau installé à
planter quelques uns pas pareil ce
qu'est le casino paul jairo paye tous
les frais médicaux de son père l'armée
lui assure un emploi stable et plus
d'argent calamine 350 euros par mois
célibataire et sans enfant il peut
donner jusqu'au 3/4 de sa solde à sa
famille
mais plus encore que donner de l'argent
jairo veut être un oncle présent
[Musique]
comme en première
en attendant une guérison du père sans
doute illusoire la famille s'en remet à
dieu et à la bienveillance du fils grâce
à l'armée jairo vient tout juste
d'obtenir une couverture sociale
indispensable pour payer l'ambulance à
bout de souffle et de force dont patrice
chouettes enfants hospitalisés
[Musique]
il faut comparer vos mains tous et puis
tu la quittes hausse et ce n'est pas
triste à son économie
le procès de john patrick you est
atteint de silicose la maladie du mineur
maladie incurable d'un autre siècle
était bien le père de jairo mériterait
d'être hospitalisé pour une longue
période
mais faute de moyens il finira ses jours
chez lui
[Musique]
à saugues à massot la capitale du bassin
minier la population subit aussi les
rejets toxiques des nombreuses usines
gourmande en charbon
c'est l'une des villes les plus polluées
de colombie
et l'extraction du charbon n'est pas
prête de s'arrêter dans le pays
c'est une des principales sur nrj de
quoi donner du travail pour longtemps
encore
ryder et ses amis
[Applaudissements]
on
bon sens
à la minera hiver comme dans toutes les
autres on entre de père en fils honni et
cousins oncles neveux ont fait partie de
la même famille celle des gueules noires
on a le même sang dans les veines
le même sang froid sous terre mais on se
fait le même sang d'encre rider est fier
de montrer à ses collègues le reportage
effectué il ya 17 ans il en est l'un des
personnages principaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alberto maîtriser ces deux mondes
médiocre mais là le staff breton
parking est importante quand on est à
orly qui nous avait tant à la clé nasa
va tenter la stricte commenté warren
[Musique]
l' esclavage infantile dans les mines a
semble-t-il diminué
[Applaudissements]
notamment grâce au combat de certains
hommes sur le terrain
[Musique]
face aux gros camions de l'industrie
minière un jeune homme s'était mobilisée
pour sauver les enfants des mines de
coopaga il leur proposait une autre
issue sans aucune aide de l'état
colombien
on a créé cette coopérative en mai 92 m
pour offrir une alternative aux enfants
mineurs de la région
ici nous avons deux activités la
sculpture sur charbon et la confection
de vêtements de travail
les enfants font surtout des figurines
précolombienne des cendriers des
presse-papier autres gadgets
ses sculptures sont ensuite vendus aux
touristes
la coopérative récupère 20% du prix de
l'objet pour ses frais de fonctionnement
et les 80% restants sont pour les gosses
par exemple avec cette figurine un
enfant gagne 10 francs pour une
demi-journée de travail soit
l'équivalent de la moitié du salaire
minimum du pays
seule une minorité des enfants de la
région travaillent ici on voudrait
qu'ils soient tous là mais on ne peut
pas les obliger à venir
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui cette coopérative existe
toujours c'est même devenu un centre
référence de lutte contre le travail
infantile
le bâtiment a fait peau neuve mais le
responsable lui n'a pas changé donne
floraux alvarez tel le missionnaire est
toujours là fier de nous montrer que sa
folle initiative de l'époque prospère
nous avons du mal à partir
présent à présent nationale
kariya ronald reagan en disant à 12h15
bonderman t as these petit gibier disent
aimer aimer nancy ménez et son année de
l'arrivée que dice ou tetris carlotti
raisons sont nombreuses les adolescents
fabrique toujours des figurines et la
main
sous l'oeil bienveillant de rodrigo 25
ans
mais russell peacock région
à 12 ans rodrigo faisait lui aussi ses
premiers pas à la mine mais la
coopérative la sauver
l'audience est terminée
la communication ligne la casa
la mostra la mine
pado
celle ci montre pour la fondation
mtt
la semaine rodrigo étudie la sociologie
à l'université de toundra la capitale de
la région
juste retour des choses le week-end il
consacre son temps la coopérative qui
lui permet de financer ses études
m
en 17 ans d'existence
la coopérative a sorti deux cent
cinquante enfants de la mine en 1989
la colombie s'est dotée de lois
interdisant le travail infantile
[Musique]
mais ces lois sont elles vraiment
respectée
[Musique]
non
nous décidons de mener l enquête
oscar nous présente son patron qui n'est
pas le propriétaire de la mine où il
travaille
mais l'administrateur et celui ci semble
un peu gêné par nos questions
[Musique]
les jeunes adolescents font des mines
le sujet est tabou personne n'en parle
car officiellement ça n'existe plus
oscar est lassé d'entendre ce discours
policé il tient à nous montrer que sa
réalité d'antan est toujours bien
actuelle cette réalité il a côtoie tous
les jours comme ici dans cette mine
proche de la sienne
l'estac afghane dans la requête
cette image nous aurions aimé ne jamais
la refaire
[Musique]
un enfant au travail dans une des mines
des plus officielles
l'ayant pas là le centre
[Musique]
le de croisons ni responsable ni
propriétaire a interrogé sur la question
alors oscar insiste pour nous montrer
cette vérité qu'on veut cacher
[Musique]
l'accès est interdit mais oscar prend le
risque de faire pénétrer des
journalistes
nous descendons un peu fébrile une pente
très raide mal assurée glissante
profond du boyau nous découvrons cinq
jeunes garçons profondeur 170 m oscar ne
facilite la prise de contact
elle est mineure sont deux jeunes
adolescents notre caméra crée une
tension
c'est sûr ils savent qu'ils sont dans
l'illégalité
le plus jeune qui a 12 ans ne tarde pas
à prendre la fuite
reste chez zone pas beaucoup plus vieux
et pas plus rassurés
[Musique]
de ce qu'ils nous disent ces jeunes
travaille 6 jours sur 7 de 6 heures le
matin jusqu'à 6 heures le soir
face à des êtres les acteurs connus
réponse que l'on veut bien entendre nous
apprendrons plus tard qu'il a environ 16
ans c'est triste à dire mais rien ne
semble avoir changé
[Applaudissements]
à 22 ans dont il a loué le plus vieux de
la bande
il fait office de chef il ya déjà passé
la moitié de sa vie sous terre oscar se
sent bien impuissant acteurs d'un
mauvais film qui tourne en bout
[Applaudissements]
alors comme investi d'une mission
il essaie de raisonner un de ces gamins
[Musique]
j'ai fait et comment et j'y suis
retourné j'ai la ville
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
selon l'organisation mondiale du travail
il y aurait jusqu'à 3 millions d'enfants
toujours actifs en colombie
on estime ce nombre à 350 millions à
travers le monde
[Musique]
aucune autorité ne vient inquiéter ses
mines hors la loi tout le monde ferme
les yeux sur le travail des enfants tôt
à la fin de l'interview de
l'administrateur dos car nous laissons
tourner la caméra sans qu'il le sache
d'un coup il est beaucoup moins timide
personne n'a jamais rien la politique de
la région
pour l'exploitation des enfants que tout
un pays tu es fatigue ces hommes et ces
familles
ils sont prêts à saisir la moindre
opportunité pour changer de voie
[Musique]
le frère d'oscar a réussi à prendre une
autre route
la route de la délivrance en espagne
[Musique]
il
je
herman rincon et saisonniers dans cette
usine de fruits et légumes depuis sept
ans mais avant lui aussi pioché dans le
noir à l'adolescence
[Musique]
même s'ils ne rentrent en colombie que
trois mois par an herman nous dit avoir
accompli ses rêves d'el dorado